hello everyone and welcome to this video
on Border Gateway protocol by simply
learn if you visit the website internet
hyphenmap.net you will be able to see a
network of websites scattered over plane
with Blobs of spheres representing each
website present on the internet with the
Advent of Internet revolution in the
early 2000s approximately 175 new
websites are created every minute so
around 2 lakh 52 000 new websites are
created every day worldwide the users of
the internet are obviously spread across
the globe and for someone sitting in
North Thailand trying to access a
website whose server is set up in Mexico
it is very important that the access to
this site in milliseconds but because of
the geographical distance and latency it
is very difficult to achieve this still
when you type a website in your browser
search console and click enter you are
redirected to that website in less than
a second how do you think that happens
how is it made possible that no matter
your geographical location if you try to
access a website thousands of miles away
you are able to do it in space 8 seconds
well this is where border Gateway
protocol comes into play and before we
begin if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply learn
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT Schwartzman
College of Engineering the course link
is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete area of the program being
offered and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press on
the Bell icon to know me some further
content so stay with us until the end of
this video as well we'll transfers
through the workings of Border Gateway
protocol so let's get started so let's
start this video with what is border
Gateway protocol or bgp bgp is a
protocol used by routers on the internet
to figure out the best way to send data
between different Networks it helps
routers exchange information and make
decisions on the most efficient parts to
send data packets across the internet
The Internet Is Lost and the amount of
data that Glides through the internet is
gigantic so how does bgp Works in that
so let's understand the working of
Border Gateway protocol
the Border Gateway protocol or bgp is
the internet's routing protocol that
connects networks worldwide while it may
seem simple at first but bgp is actually
complex in a flat local area Network
online devices can communicate using
local network addresses and can easily
connect with each other however when an
organization has multiple lengths they
need to interconnect them to connect
different lens routers are used to
forward requests between them for
example if node a wants to reach node C
on a different Lan the request must go
through the router that can forward the
request to the network where node C is
located this type of routing is
relatively straightforward and relies on
internal routing protocols including
internal bgp within the organization
however large organizations and isps
manage connectivity for multiple Network
sites and location after forming an
autonomous system while individual
networks within Nas handle routing for
their own local traffic a bgp router is
responsible for directing all the
inbound and outbound traffic between the
As and the internet
the internet consists of numerous
autonomous systems and bgp ensures that
packets are properly forwarded between
them when a bgp router connects to a
neighboring as router known as external
bgp it possesses routing tables
containing information about the
available paths on the global internet
so border Gateway protocol offers
several key benefits that make it an
indispensable part of the internet
infrastructure so let's take a closer
look at these advantages of Border
Gateway protocol
the first one is efficient routing bgp
enables efficient routing by determining
the best path for data packets to reach
their destinations it takes into account
factors like Network performance cost
and policies set by Network
administrators
this ensures that data takes most
optimal route resulting in faster and
more reliable communication
scalability bgp is highly scalable
allowing the internet to accommodate the
immense growth of networks and users
with bgp the internet can seamlessly
handle the increasing number of
connected devices and networks ensuring
smooth operations even as that internet
expands
multi-homed connectivity bgp supports
multi-home connectivity which means that
an organization can connect to multiple
internet service providers
simultaneously
this provides redundancy and load
balancing as bgp can automatically
select the best part for data based on
factors like available bandwidth and
network conditions multi-homed
connectivity enhances Network
reliability and enables organizations to
distribute traffic efficiently internet
traffic control bgp gives organizations
control over their internet traffic they
can influence the flow of data by
setting policies and preferences in the
routing decisions this allows them to
prioritize certain paths avoid congested
routes or direct traffic through
specific isps or network links with bgp
organizations have the flexibility to
optimize their Network performance and
ensure efficient data transmission
internet resilience bgp enhances
internet resilience by quickly adapting
to network changes and failures if a
link or a route becomes unavailable or
congested pgp can reroute traffic
through alternative paths this Dynamic
routing capability helps maintain
connectivity even in the face of network
disruptions or field use ensuring an
interrupted communication Global
connectivity one of the most significant
benefits of bgp is its role in enabling
Global connectivity bgp allows networks
from different countries isps and
organizations to interconnect and
exchange routing information this
collaboration facilitates seamless
communication and data transfer across
borders making the internet a truly
Global Network in conclusion border
Gateway protocol offers numerous
benefits that make it an essential
component of the internet it ensures
efficient routing scalability multi-home
connectivity traffic control resilience
and and of course Global connectivity
while it's true that bgp offers the
number of benefits to the user but there
are a number of issues present with
border Gateway protocol now let's
discuss some of the challenges or issues
that can arise with border Gateway
protocol
security risk bgp can be vulnerable to
security threats such as root hijacking
or malicious attacks leading to
potential disruptions or unauthorized
traffic diversion
root flap dampening in some cases BJP
routers may experience root flapping
where Roots continuously alternate
between available and unavailable States
this can impact Network stability and
routing decisions configuration
complexity bgp configurations can be
complex requiring expertise and careful
planning to ensure proper implementation
and optimal routing lack of
standardization although bgp itself is a
standard protocol there can be variation
in its implementations across different
vendors and network devices leading to
potential interoperability challenges
lack of centralized control bgp operates
on a decentralized Model where routing
decisions are made autonomously by
routers this lack of centralized control
can make it challenging to enforce
Global routing policies or address
routing inconsistencies and this was all
for this tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and helpful let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year iobscale was simply
learns post program at cyber security
after working 30 years in the IIT sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled certified instructors I
worked with many companies before the
security analysts and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
if you like this session then like share
and subscribe if you have any questions
then you can drop them in the comment
section below thanks for watching and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here